hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week and I'm excited to see you baby
all right this week we're talking about
cmmc control SC dot
l1-3.13.5 Implement sub networks for
publicly accessible system components
that are physically or logically
separated from internal networks let's
find out what in the world they mean on
this one
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired alone
sad and you need a friend
well here's the good news
we understand you
we understand all the cmmc dfars and
nist SP 10171 compliance stuff and we
know that you've got a big workload and
you're tired and we know a lot of things
about you because we're inside of
YouTube and
it gets creepy in here but I have great
news because you found your home right
here with us at on-call compliance
Solutions where we can help you
transform from lonely and sad into happy
and glad baby by becoming your own
company's on-call compliance hero all
right let's jump into it uh so very
interesting control here and I think
this is really rooted in basic security
best practices some companies need to
have open guest networks or may have a
lab environment where they're unable to
apply the niche controls to uh and
properly secure in these cases it is
Paramount highly important the segment
the networks show that devices which are
not secured can't touch devices which
are secured now if you're a small to
mid-size office and your shoulders keep
going up and down and up and down and up
and down and you're like what are they
talking about no worries all right you
likely have everything completely locked
down or have no publicly accessible
system components cool no problem
oftentimes the way we answer this is to
acknowledge that we have no publicly
available system component however we
state that this is by Design because
that would simply be less secure than
having them let's dive into the
assessment points on this one and I
think it will soon be clear as a lead
kite for you alright so assessment Point
number one of two is determine a
publicly accessible system components
are identified uh implemented right
Network diagram identified as secure
web-based login screen to select sde
components or secure data Enclave
components that's one way to answer the
question but ultimately I think maybe a
better answer is whip out the network
diagram and let's demonstrate that to
the Assessor second assessment point is
determine if sub networks for publicly
accessible system components are
physically or logically separated from
internal Networks yes implemented the
sde web-based login screen for select
components is logically separated and
protected utilizing multi-factor
authentication and privileged identity
management in order to allow access to
non-public information so again that's a
fairly specific answer if I was to break
that down a little bit more generically
the answer for that second assessment
Point determine if sub networks for
publicly accessible system components
are physically or logically separated
from the internal networks again really
it's you know it's two parts because it
depends on how the network is put
together one you could be doing a
network diagram right and just here you
go here's our Network diagram and it
defines all that two is you may have to
actually show them if you have no sort
of diagram that defines that stuff you
may have to show them settings but
either way they've got to determine that
if they're an Assessor so hey at on call
we work with defense contractors just
like you who have had this dfar's nist
itar and cmmc compliance stuff dropped
into their laps like a seagull on a
sunny day and we teach you how to level
up and be a proper on-call compliance
hero for your company eliminating gaps
gray areas and helping get this solved
all while showing you how to leverage
compliance has your secret weapon to
land more Defense work with higher
profit margins now that's what becoming
an on-call compliance hero can do for
you if you're looking for more help
getting compliant our compliance experts
are always on call for you visit cmmc
complianceecrets.com or check out the
bio below for links to get help right
now if you love the content we're
putting out here for you
help us out with a big thumbs up on that
like button or even better smash the
Subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance turns roll it out until the
next compliance tip my friends stay safe
and secure out there and hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance see
you on the next one
[Music]